hello white ich mag den Namen also meine
Frage ist jetzt etwas lang gezogen ich
hoffe das übersteigt jetzt nicht die
videozeigkapazität also die Frage wird
so viele Wörter enthalten dass der
geneigte Zuschauer ihren Sinn zu
verstehen fast kaum in der Lage ist
warum
Twilight warum
nicht nee warum Twilight weil
ich die Bücher nicht gelesen aber
angehört habe als Hörbuch und die waren
gar nicht mal so schlecht der Film war
dagegen Kacke das heißt wir hatten
beides mit drin wir hatten was was wir
irgendwie ein bisschen mochten und wir
parodieren auch sehr gern und Twilight
hat sich perfekt Angeboten zum
parodieren und jeder hat's geguckt und
dadurch hat dann auch jeder so
nebeneffektmäßig uns geguckt darum
Twilight